hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with the
1858 match
now between paul charles murphy and
johanyakov levantal in the previous game
game nine
morphe had a winning position but he
pushed the pawn on the wrong side of the
board
then he had an equal position and then
he blundered the game in a king and pawn
end game
uh which is great for love until as he
got his second victory in the match now
this is already
uh game 10 no draws uh so nine victory
sorry
seven victories for morphe and two for
eleventh uh and the match continues and
this is one a very nice game where we
are going to learn
uh a thing or two about rook lifts now
uh without further ado let's check it
out
morphe with the white pieces opens with
e4 uh and here elemental doesn't go uh
with
the same idea as in the previous game he
went for the philadelphia defense
but rather e6 he goes for the french
defense morphe
uh grabs hold of the center with d4 and
we have d5
sorry about that and morphe goes e
captures on d5 which is something you
just don't do because uh this equalizes
the game
instantly for black uh like it's uh it's
just something you don't do the
playing the exchange uh french with
white is uh you know
as as a me the great misha once said a
crime against chess
as is basically playing for a draw but i
don't think morphy went for it uh for
those reasons i think he just didn't
care
what he played against slovental as he
uh well he didn't consider lowentel to
be his equal
nor anyone else for that matter so i i
think he just played anything
so e captures on d5 and now knight to f3
now we have knight to f6 and now we see
oh there's already
uh a completely symmetrical position
which is not something you want to
strive for with uh with white uh uh on
move three
uh so bishop to d3 we've bishop the d6
by black and
castles we have castles by black and
knight the c3
and here black breaks symmetry of course
you cannot keep
the symmetry forever so c6 and now uh
bishop to g5
pinning that knight with h6 lonetail
asks morphy what do you want to do do
you want to go back do you want to
trade here trading doesn't really make
much sense as you just help
black develop his queen so butcher back
to h4
and now bishop the g4 and this is all
standard theory in 2020 so
there's not much to improve on the
exchange french one of the reasons you
you simply don't play it
with h3 challenging the bishop and here
are nice captures characters
followed by knight b to d7 adding
another defender to the knight
so bishop to f5 here morphy wants to
play bishop captures here and then
either
get some action going on here or to uh
to this
dislodge uh logan tells pieces so here
queen to c7
and now what do you do here well now you
could go for captures but it doesn't
really matter because the queen is no
longer here you'll just be
able to recapture with the knights so
not much sense in going for that
and here rook 8 e1 by morphe now
getting the rook to the uh to the open e
file the only open file on the board and
here is what i mean by
a nice uh well lesson on rook lifts uh
and here uh
it is as of move 13 that this position
has never been reached again
some of you have been saying in the
comments that uh why don't i say that uh
it's as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game if i was making this
video
in 1858 i would say that but it'd be
weird if i said that now making the
video in 2020
that this position has never been
reached again i think it's more
earthly to say that this position has uh
never been reached again yeah sorry
about that uh because
uh i mean it has been reached for good
reasons obviously
so but it's basically the same thing uh
if i was making the video back then i'd
say
uh we have a completely new game but now
i say the position has never been
reached again
so rook 8 e8 of course logan tell gets
his rook to the only open file on the
board which is the e file
and here morphe goes rook to e3 which is
a very nice rook lift and you want to
play rook to e1 double up and hopefully
claim uh the e file for yourself now now
for those of you who are new maybe to
rook lifts uh this is something you
always want to do
so why not make a rook lift with rook to
e2 the problem with rook to e2
is that black very happily trades here
just captures captures and then rook to
e8 and it's actually black who gains
control of the e file uh for his rooks
so instead by playing rook to e3
while black can also trade now it's not
as favorable because here after captures
white will capture with the pawn and
this is uh no longer an open file
so rook to e8 will not be so so potent
uh you've improved your
control in the center you now have two
points in the center and you have a
semi-open f file to use for your queen
and for your rook
so that's why a rook to e3 is a much
better rook lift than rook to e2
i just uh thought i'd throw that in
there so rook to e3 by morphe and now
uh bishop to f4 laventille says okay
that's a bit of a too nice
overwork lift so let's just uh you know
take it back a few steps
so now morphe can either go back all the
way to e1
uh which is a possibility but morphe now
says okay now
let's trade i'm going to play rook to e2
either way and now you can claim the e
file for yourself but
only temporarily so rook captures and
now knight captures so i'm not allowing
rook 8 just yet because
knight captures here so here bishop back
to d6 and now
bishop captures on d7 by morphy
uh we have knight captures and now
knight the g3
uh preparing to get the knight over to
f5 which of course uh
uh elemental doesn't allow so bishop
captures uh
sorry not right away first rook to e8 uh
first he claims the e file for himself
which was the kind of the whole point of
the game now morphe unable to play uh
rook to e1
uh goes knights to f5 he does claim the
file for his knight
and here uh it's very hard for black to
bring his knight
back into the game for example if you go
just knight f6 then knight captures on
h6 you capture and the queen picks up
the knight so
the knight has to do something else so
while bishop to f
here bishop to f8 here would seem uh
like a reasonable idea
love intel goes knight back to f8 now he
wants to bring the knight to h7 and then
to g5
so morphe goes bishop back to g3 he
offers a trade now
we have captures captures and now rook
to e4 another very nice rook lift
putting pressure on the pawn here so for
the moment the knight cannot move and
here
c3 morphe just adds more protection to
the d4 pawn
and now knight to h7 preparing knight to
g5 to go after the queen on f3
so h4 morphy stops that and here h5 love
until again with his tricks
trying to get morphe to go for the pawn
where he would uh
fall victim to g6 and even though you
have some checks for example check check
and check
uh you don't have anything for example
if you if you sacrifice the
the knight there's just no attack
happening here and black is very happy
being up a piece
so after this h5 move with c4 by morphy
trying to overload the pawn you cannot
defend both of these guys
uh and now comes uh well a move that
really shouldn't have happened for
leventhal uh he should go queen
somewhere like d7 or d8 keep an eye on
the d5 pawn
uh also maybe queen b6 put pressure uh
put more pressure on on this pawn making
it hard for the knight to move
try and bait c5 also a possibility but
he played knight to f6 it's like he
completely forgot
why he rerouted the knight all the way
from f8 to h7
and he just played knight back to f6 but
luckily uh
you haven't and you've been paying
attention so now feel free to pause the
video and
win this game for morphe uh while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on paying
attention
and you know exactly what's happening
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's of course
knight captures and g7 same idea as with
grabbing the h
pawn now you you don't capture and
capture tonight but you just eliminate
the defender of the knight
so here capturing this loses terribly
just captures with
czech king f8 uh king j8 also loses uh
but i'm just gonna show king of fade
because it's much nicer
uh queen h8 check forcing king is seven
and now a nice
rook sacrifice captures queen h7 check
king moves and you pick up the queen so
that beautiful stuff right there so
after knight captures on g7
uh lointel said okay i can't capture the
knight right away however
knight to g4 and you know the the
position is a bit more complicated now
but
not for morphe he just captures the h
pawn and now says
what do you what do you have here we
have rook characters on d4
and now morphy uh goes into a fourth
trade knight f6
check we have captures and the queen
captures here and now
uh what do you play here uh well here uh
it's uh
it's a really a tough position but the
only way to prolong the game
for black and to keep fighting is rook
to g4 and rook to g4 is a key defensive
move for black here
however long tell said uh why why don't
i just
grab another pawn and that's exactly
what he did he played rook captures on
c4
but now uh you know once again feel free
to
pause the video and win this game for
morphe once again
while i give you a few more seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding the
uh uh unstoppable mating threat and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's rook to f5 and now you will see
that there is no defense against
rook h5 to rook h8 checkmate so if the
rook was here
uh just rook g7 prevents that as the
queen would not be able to guard this
square so laventille thought
okay i can still play my rook to g4 and
yes now if morphe goes rook h5 rook g7
stops checkmate
however uh he missed that while you can
also
do this checkmate this way you can also
do it this way and now there's not much
you can do here uh here we have
queen to c7 uh sorry queen to c8 if you
go king to f8 to try and prevent this
uh wow this rook uh a rook lift
just queen h6 check now the king has to
go back uh
or rather if you go back it's checkmate
so you'd have to block with the rook
uh and then just rook to g5 and the
white wins the rook so that's out of the
out of the question so after this rook
the e5
now threatening this queen to c8
guarding the e
d8 square but now comes rook to e7
going after the f7 pawn there was a
there was a quicker way to end the game
here for morphe just rook h5
and now the the point is after rook to
g7 stopping checkmate you just have
queen h6
it's unstoppable and uh the point you
have to find is king f8 now rook g5
again wins the rook uh but morphy
known for his uh playing moves instantly
and uh
not really thinking that his opponents
are able to defend
goes for rook to e7 so he allows a a
nice temporary defensive idea
we have queen to f8 guarding the pawn
here and now
queen to e5 by morphy now threatening uh
rook the e8 uh to win the queen
uh and here it seems like you can uh
save yourself with rook to e4 but it
doesn't it only appears that way because
the rook the e4
well it looks great it's really not
because queen g5
check queen to g7 blocks and now you
simply trade off everything captures
captures captures captures
and although to an untrader trained eye
it seems that the game is
only uh beginning here uh if you know
your king and pawn end games you know
that
black is completely lost here so here
white plays g4
prevents black from playing f5 and the
kingdom pawn end game is winning for
white because
of the past h pawn white is just too
fast so
if black doesn't stop white king from uh
grabbing this pawn
then he's just gonna win easily and if
he tries to do exactly that
then king e3 and now you start pushing
the h pawn the black king will have to
go after it and then you're just going
to start gobbling up material
so while it seems that you can maybe
hold
morphy probably knew this when he played
rook to e7
and then of course he he missed nothing
so queen to g7 offering the queen trade
but now
rook to e8 with check we have king to h7
now comes queen to h5 check
and it was in this position on move 34
that yohanyako blavintal resigned the
game and game 10
of the match goes to paul charles morphy
which uh who now leads the match
eight to two so here you resign because
uh the king has nowhere to go your only
move here is to block with the queen but
then the rook is left
defenseless and queen captures just ends
the game
so really really uh amazing stuff i hope
you enjoyed that little bit about rook
lifts for those of you who are maybe new
to
new to chess i hope you found that um a
little bit of information valuable
uh and uh uh well this whole uh this
whole uh
uh this whole game was just uh very
interesting because the levanthal
realized that it was really really
difficult to bring the knight back into
the game from that d7 square
and then it's like he completely forgot
uh wha
what was happening like he he
deliberately rerouted the knight like
this
uh and then in the end he still put it
on f6 which
i mean just loses the game for him so
low intel
great player great positional player
understands chess understands like the
basic principles the end game
uh i mean he understands what's
happening but he just
misses uh a little little things like
this so
and it's something that uh that was a
common trait amongst
a lot of morphe opponents in those days
but like i said we are going further
with the saga we're going to meet some
stronger opponents and it's going to be
it's going to be pretty wild
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it uh if you're wondering about what is
the age of kaisa and what is the
countdown well it's something that i'm
going to explain in a video
that will be uh solely made for
addressing that but it's
basically a project we've been working
on for like a year and a half
it's basically a chess manga and for
those of you who will say
but it's not a manga if it's not coming
from japan uh okay it's it's
just manga slash chess comic slash web
series
uh kind of thing where we where we you
know have fun try to promote
chess and our first chapter is being
published in exactly two days
on the uh new website agatmator.com
which
yet uh is not public but it will be yeah
in two days but i will
will inform you as i i'm planning to
make a separate video on that
uh but we already i have some social
media so if you're interested in
following the age of kaisa
if you want to be one of the first
followers to get some uh you know little
bits of information do check it out the
first link in the description below will
be a link to age of kai'sa twitter page
uh where you can you know uh follow
what's happening what's uh what's going
to be published
you can ask questions everything will be
answered of course and it's going to be
a lot of fun
so uh once again i do hope you enjoyed
it i would like to thank david kimura
christopher reynolds
andreas weidiger ivy and nicolas kiefer
for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
morphe saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day